so does the next group jamaican-born but
they came up into you change spoken word
artist hip-hop artists and Muslim
sisters put your hands together for
poetic pilgrimage things I like hold on
what's happening here we're connected to
two very misunderstood realities one
being hip-hop and one being Islam and I
think for us as cuesta pilgrimage even
though we didn't set out to be this
bridge between any two communities in a
way I think we kind of are so many
people have inaccurate ideas of what
being a Muslim is and what being a
Muslim women is about that we need to
express ourselves because if we don't
then other people would speak for us
it's important for Muslim women's voices
to be heard because we are so often
spoken about our relationship with
hip-hop is the genesis of hip-hop it's
like giving that a voice to the people
that were voiceless it's about
representing the underrepresented most
important for Muslim women to be present
in places that we don't expect it to be
because I think that that's where change
happens with portable image we strive to
change our world and our reality in
hopes that it will have a ripple effect
in changing how the wider community view
women Muslims black women we're just
trying to be an embodiment of that and
hope that it will change the world